Let's go next to Justin from Albany or
Albany, New York. I love both pronunciations.
I'm surprised as I just never joined the service
before I was the first. And I've already called.
Wow. Wow. What's going on?
I'm just curious. I've been a viewer
for a while and yes, just with the right wing.
And this is a complex issue. So it's kind of hard
to summarize it in a couple of sentences.
But like I look at their attitude towards
LGBT people, for example, like transgender youth
with one of their big targets. And it's just like,
do they do you do we think that
it's just these people really just
not realize that they have an impact on
families directly who, like, work hard,
just provide the best things for their children?
Are they are they targeting those type of people?
Is it just a convenient tool for votes
or do they really if they really think
they're doing the right thing?
I don't think there's one answer.
I think the motivations are different for
different right wingers, like, for example, on
generally speaking, on LGBT issues. There are some
right wingers who have the positions they have
because either for religious reasons or whatever
cultural reasons they are scared of or believe
that LGBT individuals are bad people or immoral
or satanic or demonic or whatever, there's that
group. There's also sort of more I don't know if
cynical is the right word, but more opportunistic
right wingers who see these cultural issues
as wedge issues around which you can, No. One,
get people fired up and no to raise money and
maybe even win elections. So I don't think there's
like one explanation, to be perfectly frank.
That's a fair point. I just I just it's something
that just in my mind, I just feel is kind of
tragic because there's just these are real people,
I guess, like Transue is like one of the big
wedge wedge issues. It's just it just makes me
sad because, you know, it's just it's real people
and real families that that get impacted by that,
which is why I'm passionate about that issue.
Well, you know, one good piece of news is
a study came out earlier this week, a new poll
where I guess for the first time in history,
even a majority of Republicans now think gay
marriage should be legal. Now, of course,
the battle lines have moved on that issue
because gay marriage is legal nationally and
it has been for four years. It's more about,
you know, religious freedom to be homophobic
or trans. But I still think that the numbers are
slowly continuing to move in the right direction.
That's what my friend told me, which
is like I feel like most people in the
country are ready to move on from, like
the gay marriage issue, especially just.
But six years later, six years later, they're
starting to move on from it. That tells you how
slowly they move.
You know,
that's a fact. Well, thanks, David. My pleasure.
Thank you for the call. Some good calls. We
had that sort of bad start with with a
dropped call, but so far it's going OK.
Let's go next to ible. Is it pronounced
Jatt with a T from Tallahassee, Florida?
Yes, it is. How are you? But can
you hear me? I can hear you fine.
All right, I wanted to make a very urgent comment
in response to your award winning bonus show. OK,
from about two weeks ago. Sure. And you were
talking about going to a Thai restaurant
and then having some soup there, right?
And.
I have actually tie American, so I wanted to make
a correction to the pronunciation. Excuse me.
Let me guess, is it my pronunciation of galangal?
No, actually, enti, that verb is known as
Colectivo A. Yeah, like is the transliteration,
I think, wow, but the actually, I don't I didn't
even know it was called Galangal in English,
but it was actually the name of the soup.
And I think you called it Tom Yum, but it's
high, it's actually pronounced Tom Young. Wow.
Well, listen, I stand corrected. I never
purport to know Thai pronunciation,
but the soup this is one of the I would
argue globally one of the best soups. And
I would not want to disrespect that with a wrong
pronunciation. So I do appreciate the correction.
Yeah, it's quite interesting
because a lot of Americans called
Pad Thai with like a Puti as pad Thai, right.
So that's another common one that's out there.
Well, listen, you don't have
to know how to pronounce it,
to love it. I think that's the
upside for everybody listening.
Yeah, it's always a good question as to
when you correct pronunciation of food
in another language, right. Kind of interesting.
It's just it's just if it's I guess if it's
more commonly have been known about, then
people can have the right pronunciation.
Can you get good again? Either Tom Yum
or Tom Youm in Tallahassee, Florida.
Actually, I haven't looked for it, I found it on
the menus here. Interesting, a Thai restaurants.
All right. Well, I appreciate
the call in the correction.
Sure. All right, very good. Let's go
next to. Lot of corrections happening,
which is fine, I'm glad to be corrected,
corrected, I want to do better.